well on the heels of that new york city
main time taking a pretty aggressive
approach to get more people vaccinated
people will now be required to show
proof of vaccination when entering an
indoor business victoria saha tells us
what people here in las vegas have to
think about that
when you got vaccinated you were given
this your proof of vaccination card and
if you're going to be going to new york
city you're going to need to show this
before you enter indoor businesses but
will this trend follow us here in las
vegas
in southern nevada every opportunity is
being given for tourists and locals to
get vaccinated before any vaccine
mandates come into place that just is
one tool that you know
may be used heidi parker with immunized
nevada couldn't say if we would follow
new york city as an effort but says we
should have our vaccine cards handy
because businesses here have every right
to ask for it attorney matthew hoffman
agrees
there's really nothing you can do no
shirt no shoes no vaccination no service
as long as it's applied equally to
everybody
it's inherently not discriminatory i
asked tourists on the strip if they had
concerns about showing proof of
vaccination here with a place like las
vegas there would be a lot of pushback
i think people wouldn't want to come
people are already you know
feeling bad about just having to wear a
mask it's no different than showing my
driver's license if somebody asked for
it i carry it with me just now as i
travel even
locally when i'm at home i carry with me
just in case to me it's not a big deal
if you can't get vaccinated because of
ongoing health concerns hoffman says
this is where it can get a little tricky
because private businesses can still
deny you entry just so they can be fair
to everyone victoria saha 8 news now
and by the way new york city's proof of
vaccine mandate goes into effect
september 13th